I've spoken before parliaments, kings,
queens, leaders of the world.
I've been doing this for a long time.
But this is intimidating.
Following
you all are incredible.
I unless they one thing to rest,
I may be a practicing Catholic priest
to go to seven 30 mass
every morning in high school
and gone on to college before
I went to the black church.
Not a joke. And he knows this.
And it's so great to see you, man.
You're one of the greatest we've ever had.
We really are. And
And then I took on apartheid
in South Africa and a whole lot else.
They didn't want to see him coming,
but we used to
that's when we would organize, to march
or to desegregate the city.
My state was like,
You're segregated by law.
We were a slave state.
So our great shame
and we had a lot of leftovers
of the bad things
came from that period of time. But
I anyway, That's another time.
But I learned a lot.
And I promise
if any preacher preached to me back
then, I'm not going to be nearly
as long as you were
actually have a bad reputation
for speaking too long.
He followed the path of Moses,
a leader of inspiration,
calling on the people not to be afraid.
And always, always,
as my grandfather said, keep the faith.
He followed the path of Joseph
a believer in dreams and the divinity
they carry and the promise they hold.
And like John the Baptist
he prepared us for the greater hope ahead.
Juan, who came to bear witness the late
Reverend Dr.
Martin Luther King Jr.
Was a nonviolent warrior for justice.
Who followed the word in a way
of his lord and savior.
On this day of remembrance,
we gather at Dr.
King's cherished Ebenezer.
I say emphasize the word
cherished Ebenezer.
And, by the way, says every good man
every good brother in
is a really strong, strong sister.
You think I'm king
I know Dr.
King and my sisters, not you,
but I tell you what.
She's smarter, better
looking, a better person.
Than I have managed all my campaigns,
folks,
you know.
On this day of remembrance,
as we gather here at its cherished
Ebenezer to commemorate
what would have been Dr.
King's 94th birthday
we gather to contemplate his moral vision
and to commit ourselves to his path,
his path,
the path
that leads to the beloved community,
to the sacred place.
That sacred hour
when justice rains down like
waters and righteousness
as a mighty stream.
Folks, to the King family,
I know no matter how many years pass
doesn't matter how many years pass.
Those days of remembrance are difficult.
They bring everything back
as if it happened yesterday.
It's hard for you.
I don't want to thank the King family.
Presumptuous me to do this,
but on behalf of the whole congregation
for being willing to do this year
in and year out,
because you give so much, so much
to the rest of us.
And we love you all we love your
the fully honor.
Dr. King, we have to pay tribute to Mrs.
Coretta Scott King, who we dearly miss
She led the movement
to create a King holiday and so much more.
My view, this is her day as well.
And Raphael Warnock,
Reverend Dr.
Senator
congratulations on your historic victory
A fellow Morehouse man
I've come to know a lot of Morehouse men
and all saying
I can't tell him much
but I tell you what,
we've shut up.
For the first time ever in the White
House, the divine nine committed
act of every day
and I watch how the other graduates
pick on the Morehouse man
you stand on Dr.
King's pulpit
and you carry on his purpose.
And the service doesn't
stop at the church door.
It didn't with Dr.
King done with you, done with the vast
majority.
You stand there,
you've said you before me.
I want to thank you for the honor
inviting me to be a call
to America's America's Freedom Church.
And thank you to this congregation
and to all the distinguished
guests, elected, non-elected officials
that are here today
who've done so much over so many years
and so many young people are going to do
so much more than we were ever.
What's your name, honey?
It's good to see you.
Maybe I can have a picture with you
and before I leave.
Okay.
That all right?
I say this with all sincerity.
I stand here humble
being the first sitting president.
United States
to have an opportunity
to speak at Ebenezer Sunday service.
You've been around 436 years.
I know I look like you, but I haven't
I'm god-fearing, thanks to my parents,
and not as a priest who taught me in
school, but i am no preacher.
But I've tried
to walk my faith, as all of you have.
I stand here
inspired by the preacher
who is one of my only political heroes.
I've been saying that, and he's heard me
say for years,
i've two political heroes my entire life.
And I started off as a 22 year old kid.
This side of the civil rights movement
got elected to the united states senate.
I was 29 and got no love to take office.
And two heroes, Bobby Kennedy.
I admired John Kennedy, but I could never
picture him at my kitchen table.
But I could. Bobby
and know malarkey.
Dr. King.
And the fact is that
you know, I stand here
at a critical juncture for the
United States and the world, in my view.
Rather, what I've
some of my colleagues are tired of hear
me say one word of what
we call an inflection point.
One of those points in world history
where what happens the last few years
will happen, the next six or eight years
are going to determine
what the world looks like
for the next 30 to 40 years.
It happened after World War Two.
It's happening again.
The world is changing.
There's much at stake
much at stake.
And, you know,
the fact is that
this is the time and choosing
this is the time
and choosing direct choices.
We have
our way of people
who choose democracy over autocracy.
Couldn't ask that question.
15 years ago that democracy was settled,
not for African-Americans.
But democracy
as an institutional structure was settled.
But it's not
it's not
We have to choose a community over chaos,
a way that people are going to choose
love over hate
These are the vital questions of our time.
And the reason
why I'm here is your president.
I believe Dr.
King's life and legacy
show us the way we should pay attention.
I really do.
Dr. Martin
Luther King was born in a nation
where segregation
was a tragic fact of life.
He had every reason to believe, as others,
as a generation did, that history
had already been written that the division
would be America's destiny.
But he rejected that outcome.
Micah's command to do justice,
love, mercy, and walk humbly
and so often when people hear about Dr.
King.
People think of his ministry
and the movement
where most about the epic struggle
for civil rights and voting rights.
What we do well to remember
that his mission was something even deeper
It was spiritual.
It was moral.
The goal of the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference was Dr.
King led stated clearly and boldly,
and it must be repeated again now
to redeem the soul of America.
I'm not joking.
To redeem the soul of America.
What is what is the soul of America?
Easy to say. What is the soul of America?
Well, the soul is the breath,
the life, the essence.
Of who we are.
The soul makes us. US
the soul of America is embodied
in a sacred proposition
that we're all created equal
in the image of God.
That was the sacred proposition
for which for which Dr.
King gave his life.
The sacred proposition rooted in scripture
and enshrined
in the Declaration of Independence,
a sacred proposition
he invoked on that day
in 1963 when he told my generation
about his dream
dream
in which we're all entitled to be treated
with my father's favorite word, dignity
and respect.
A dream in which we all deserve
liberty and justice.
And it's still the task of our time
to make that dream a reality
because it's not there. Yet
to make Dr.
King's vision tangible,
to match the words of the preachers
and the poets with our deeds.
As the Bible teaches us,
we must be doers of the word
doers of the Word.
The battle for the soul of this
nation is perennial.
It's a constant struggle
it's a constant struggle
between hope and fear.
Kindness and cruelty.
Justice and injustice
against those who
trafficking and racism,
extremism and insurrection.
A battle fought on battlefields
and bridges
from courthouses
and ballot boxes to pulpits and protest.
And at our best,
the American promise wins out.
At our best, we hear and heed
the injunctions of the Lord
and the whispers of the angels.
But I don't need to tell you
that we're not always at our best.
We're fallible.
We fail and fall.
But faith and history teaches us
that however dark the night,
joy cometh in the morning
and that joy
comes with the commandments of Scripture.
Love the Lord thy God with all my heart,
all my mind and all my soul.
And love thy neighbor.
As thyself.
Easy to say.
But very hard to do.
But do not commandment.
In my view, lies
the essence of the gospel.
And the essence of the American promise.
When we see each other as neighbors
and not enemies,
the progress and justice come.
So we see each other
as fellow human beings,
as children of God.
That we bend began to walk the path of Dr.
King's beloved community,
a path his dream inspired
and his legacy propel
us forward to this day.
Here's what I learned in my life
and my career along that path.
As many of you have learned along
your path,
we're all imperfect beings.
We don't know where
and what fate will deliver to us
and when what we do, we can do our best
to seek a life of light and hope
and love
And yes, truth, truth
That's what I try to do every day
to build the future we all want.
Or reminding ourselves that nothing
nothing is guaranteed in our democracy.
Nothing.
Every generation is required
to keep it defended.
Protect it
to be repairs of the bridge,
and to remember that the power
to redeem the soul of America lies
where it always has lie
lay in the hands of we the people.
We the people
I was vividly reminded
of that truth.
On the South Lawn of the White House,
I believe you were there.
Both of you, both your senators,
the the South Lawn of the White House
and our vice president, Kamala Harris,
and hearing these words, and I quote,
it took just one generation
from segregation
to the Supreme Court
of the United States and of, quote,
Those are the words of cogent,
cogent cations.
Who drowned Jackson?
Our Supreme Court justice
took just one generation of segregation.
The Supreme Court
of the United States
As I told folks at the time.
She's smarter than you are.
As Dr.
King said,
give us the ballot
and we will place judges on the bench.
Who will do justly
And we are.
That's the promise of America,
where change is hard but necessary
excuse me.
Progress is never easy,
but it's always possible
The things do get better.
And our marched toward
a more perfect union.
But at this inflection point,
we know there's a lot of work
to ask to continue in economic justice.
Civil rights.
Voting rights.
Protecting our democracy.
And I'm remembering
that our job is to redeem
the soul of America.
Look,
I get accused of being an inveterate
optimist.
I call that the Irish of it.
We're never on top, always stepped on.
But we were optimistic,
like Dr.
King was optimistic.
Folks
as I said,
progress is never easy.
Redeeming
the soul of the country
is absolutely essential.
I doubt whether any of us
would have thought,
even in Dr.
King's time, that the literally
the institutional structures
of this country might collapse
like you're seen in Brazil
or seen in other parts of the world.
Folks
are closer. This
with a blessing
I see today in the Oval Office
and many of you been there.
Been there in my office.
You get to set
it up the way you want within reason.
As I sit at my desk
as I sit at my desk
and look at the fireplace,
just to the left
is the bust of Dr.
King.
Is there in that spot on purpose?
Because he was my inspiration as a kid.
He does know
where we should go
I ran for three reasons.
I said I wanted to restore
the soul of America.
I wanted to rebuild this country
from the bottom up, in the middle out.
And I wanted to unite it
and not far from him, if you look
about 40, 50 degrees to the right.
There is another
statue
another bust
of Rosa Parks.
People
ask me why
I say I put in my words,
she just say, I've had enough
I've had enough.
Folks.
I often think of the question that Dr.
King asked us all those years ago.
I think it's important
you all remember but this is important.
The nation remember it,
he said.
Where do we go from here?
That's a quote Where do we go from here?
Well, my message
to the nation on this day
is we go forward.
We go together
when we choose democracy.
Over autocracy,
a beloved community over chaos.
We choose believers in the dreams
to be doers.
To be unafraid.
Always keeping the faith.
Every time I walk out of my Irish-Catholic
grandfather's
home up in Scranton, Pennsylvania,
his name was Ambrose Finnegan.
And Joe Joey, keep the faith.
My grandmother. No, Joey.
Spread it.
Spread the faith. Now, I'm serious.
It's a Catholic grocery.
I have my wrist.
One my son had on a day night.
He was dying.
The point is, there's hope.
There's always hope.
We have to believe in.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that was Dr.
King's path, in my view,
path of keeping the faith
It must be our path.
Folks, for God's sake,
this is the United States of America.
The United States.
There's nothing beyond our capacity.
Nothing beyond our capacity.
If we set our mind to it.
And ladies and gentlemen, we're
a land of dreamers and a land of doers.
Nothing is beyond our capacity
in the gospel song that Dr.
King loved,
as I understand he's always told, he did.
We've come too far from where we started.
Nobody told me that
the road would be easy.
I don't believe he brought
me this far to leave me.
He did not care this far to leave me.
My fellow Americans, I don't think
the Lord brought us this far to leave us.
I really don't.
My word lady.
My fellow Americans.
God bless Dr.
Martin Luther King and his family.
And based on his one of his favorite
hymns, Precious Lord, take my hand
through the storm, through the night
and lead me on to the light.
May God bless you all.
Let's go find the light.
We can do this.
I hate
to do